ja willkommen zu aktuellen Sitzung zur
Vorlesung heute möchte ich Ihnen zum
ersten Mal bevor wir zum eigentlichen
Thema kommen nämlich der Wiederholung
möchte ich Ihnen
zunächst mal das begriffsnetz vorstellen
und Sie finden auch alle Folien jetzt
auf Ilias sie können auf Ilias gehen
wenn sie es interessiert können Sie sich
herunterladen genau die Folien jetzt
auch präsentieren können Sie zum
Beispiel gleich Kommentare reinmachen
wenn Sie wollen
also zum begriffsnetz das habe ich ja
angedeutet gehabt
da bin ich jetzt eben ein paar Begriffe
vorstellen heißt ja Grundbegriffe der
praktischen Philosophie die wir bisher
kennengelernt haben das können Sie alles
aber auch noch sehen auf der Datei die
haben sehr bekommen geschickt also da
gibt's hier erst Personen damit haben
wir angefangen dann haben wir uns
überlegt ja individuelle Personen gibt
es so wie Sie und ich dann gibt's
vielleicht kollektive Personen also ich
versuche hier so ein bisschen
aufgliederungsunternehmen das kann man
schon mal ein bisschen natürlich
diskutieren da kann sie natürlich weiter
fragen was macht eine Person aus könnte
man weiter diskutieren Selbstbewusstsein
und so weiter und so fort oder der Wille
Frankfurt dann haben wir gesagt die
Person handelt ob individuell oder
Kollektiv
mit der Handlung hängt natürlich der
Bille zusammen der hängt natürlich
irgendwie auch mit dem kollektiven
zusammen und der Wille muss vom Wunsch
unterschieden werden der Wunsch man kann
sich vieles Wünschen der Wunsch kann
auch anderen Wünschen widersprechen wir
brauchen auf der wunschbasis jetzt nicht
unbedingt eine Einheit haben oder
kohärent zu sein
Wünsche sind ihr so Fantasien auch
häufig
Wünsche sind nicht verbindlich wenn ich
mir etwas Wünsche heißt es nicht dass
ich es auch tun möchte dass ich will
also wurden schon viele müssen
verschieden werden
dann haben wir noch den Begriff des
Grundes Hammer eingeführt
also Wille und der
Grundbegriff hängen miteinander zusammen
Gründe kann man ganz verschiedene
Hinsichten verstehen man kann es
verstehen als motivationalen ganz
verstehen als explikativ oder normativ
Stichwort gute Gründe und dann haben wir
natürlich in der letzten Sitzung der
vorletzten Sitzung schon mit dem
Vernunftbegriff zu tun gehabt und auch
die Vernunft kann man wieder
unterscheiden in die instrumentelle
Vernunft das waren die hypothetischen
Imperativ kann und man kann sie am
unterscheiden in eine am moralische von
muss natürlich heißen ich habe zwei
geschrieben die von 0 ist wiederum als
die Rationalität die muss man natürlich
auch wieder Irrationalität in eine
Beziehung bringen und das haben in der
letzten Sitzung gemacht und Beispiel der
Willensschwäche der aggressia also hier
müsste jetzt moralische verstehen mir
geht's nur darum zu zeigen dass
behandeln nicht immer irgendwie
vernünftig sein muss da gibt's eine
große Debatte drüber handeln wir auch
irrational und das zum Thema
willenschwäche und in eine der kommenden
Sitzung werden wir auch die Frage
behandeln wie es zu denken ist dass wir
unoradisch warum handeln wir den
manchmal unmoralisch oder sogar böse
auch das ist so ein Fall den man häufig
im Kontext der willenschwäche oder der
Irrationalität diskutiert ich werde
jetzt auch dieses begriffsnetz immer
weiter vervollständigen nein in der
nächsten Sitzung wird hier gleich noch
ein bisschen was weiteres dranhängen wir
werden es nämlich heute mit dem Thema
Freiheit zu tun bekommen aber zunächst
mal mit der etwas
anspruchsloseren Form von Freiheit der
basalfreiheit die jeder Kunde zu geben
würde ja am meisten von uns nämlich
Handlungsfreiheit und wie immer kann man
da auch andere Formen unterscheiden
nämlich hier die Willensfreiheit und die
Willensfreiheit in der nächsten Sitzung
geben also im ganzen alles sein Thema
und ich kann schon ein bisschen
vorwegnehmen in der nächsten Sitzung
werden wir hier das Begriff Netz weiter
aus und hier unten werden dann nächsten
Sitzung die Begriffe determination
Notwendigkeit und Indifferenz oder
Kontingenz ist nicht genau dasselbe noch
stehen also Freiheit kann man
diskutieren vor der Frage vor dem
Hintergrund der Frage sind wir frei wenn
wir der terminiert sind der Naturgesetze
der terminieren uns sie legen uns
irgendwie fest oder sie bestimmen uns
wir bestimmen unseren selbst dann kann
man den Begriff der Notwendigkeiten
Spiel bringen verträgt sich Freiheit
welche Art auch immer sie jetzt zeigt
Notwendigkeit und wie verträgt sich
Freiheit mit Indifferenz Indifferenz
bedeutet dass ich eigentlich gar keinen
Grund habe oder dass die Gründe sich
total aufwiegen die Waage die willensage
die hält sich genau das Gleichgewicht ja
wenn die Gründe genau gleich schwer
wieder ist eine große Debatte ist es
sinnvoll Freiheit als Indifferenz oder
als Gleichgewicht oder man sagt auch
manchmal equilibrismus
equilibrium heißt das Gleichgewicht
stellen sich das wie eine Waage vor in
der willenswaage links und rechts liegen
die Gründe für Sie genau gleich schwer
und sie haben ein equilitium ein
Gleichgewicht und wie können sie sich
aus Gleichgewicht heraus überhaupt
entscheiden ja und eine weitere Frage
ist natürlich auch so was wie
Willkürlichkeit das haben wir auch schon
ein bisschen diskutiert verstreckt sich
das mit Freiheit als ich wollte nur
andeuten hier auf der linken Seite wird
einiges noch ergänzt werden und auf der
rechten Seite werden wir dann hier die
Fragen diskutieren im Folgenden die
sowas wie moralische Motivation
betreffen die das moralisch gute
betreffen die aber auch sowas wie Normen
treffen
das ist jetzt vorerst mal nur das
begriffsnetz und am Ende des Semesters
haben sie die aller Weise ein ganz
großes weit verzweigtes und immer auch
schön verbundenes begriffsnetz und dann
können Sie wenn Sie sich auf die Klausur
vorbereiten das einfach sich hernehmen
wie schon sagt und eine Kommilitonin ein
Kommilitone bitten doch mal einen
Begriff anzusetzen und sie sollen dann
von diesem Begriff die ganzen weiteren
Verästelungen begründen also Freiheit
und Wille die hängt das Miteinander
sagen oder Handlungsfreiheit wie verhält
sich Handlungsfreiheit zur
instrumentellen von oder zum Wunsch sie
können also beliebige Verbindung
herstellen und das wenn Sie das können
dann sind sie ganz flexibel mit dem
begriffen und können ganz beliebig jetzt
endlich am ja sich orientieren darum
geht es geht um die Orientierung in
diesem Begriff
ja nachdem ich jetzt diese Begriff
selbst vorgestellt habe möchte ich hier
zum Rückblick übergehen zur letzten
Sitzung wir hatten sie mit dem Thema
Willensschwäche zu tun und das habe ich
jetzt im begriffsnitz als eine Form von
praktischer Irrationalität dargestellt
als Willensschwäche betrifft das
Verhältnis von unserem Willen unseren
Wissen über die Situation und unsere
Handlung
und ganz kurz formuliert kann man sagen
wir tun nicht das wofür die meisten
besten Gründe sprechen obwohl wir es tun
könnten obwohl wir als frei wären das zu
tun wir handeln wieder besseres Wissen
und Verwandte Begriff ist die
Unbeherrschtheit die agrasier auf
Englisch heißt der Begriff im Kontinents
ist ein bisschen spät ist dann ins
Deutsche zu übertragen ich verwende
jetzt immer Unbeherrschtheit und
Willensschwäche bedeutet das Wille und
Vernunft nicht übereinstimmen oder sogar
eigentlich genau genommen Handlung will
und Vernunft nicht übereinstimmt weil
Video und von 15 sie ja eigentlich sehr
einig aber die Handlung folgt nicht aus
dieser Einheiten von Wille deswegen kann
man sagen ist eine Form von praktischer
Beratung also Irrationalität würde jetzt
auch noch beschäftigen z.B kann man sich
die Frage stellen wie schon sagte ist
unmoralisches Handeln eine Form von
Willen Schwäche das wäre zum Beispiel
auch spannende Frage für den Typ 2 von
der Klausur unmoralisches Handel müssen
wir überhaupt erst noch diskutieren was
ist das überhaupt oder sogar böses
handeln aber prima Fazit ist doch völlig
irrational dass eine Person die weiß was
gut und schlecht ist also was moralisch
geboten ist
und es sollte man ja eigentlich
voraussetzen das ist eine Person weiß
dass die trotzdem gegen die moralische
Norm verstößt ja wie kommt es dass
Personen aus Freiheit aus eigener
Entscheidung weil sie sind ja auch
verantwortlich für betragen gegen das
moralisch geboten und das ungerade tun
und am Ende vielleicht sogar noch der
Auffassung sind dass sie eigentlich das
Gute tun was passiert nämlich auch so
häufig
aber es passiert auch manchmal dass
Menschen einfach das Böse um das bösen
Willen tun das gibt manchmal eben auch
in selten Feld und dann muss man sich
wirklich fragen was passiert da
eigentlich ja und es wird jetzt erstmal
naheliegend zu sagen das ist das ist
Willens Schwäche aber ich glaube nicht
dass wir das moralisch Böse das
unmoralischen Handeln im Sinne adäquat
verstehen können darüber werden aber
noch mal genauer diskutieren wenn es zum
Thema moralisch böses geht dann habe ich
jetzt in der letzten Sitzung die
zugenommen auf Donald da sitzen das ist
auch ein Urgestein der sogenannten
analytischen Philosophie genauer gesagt
eben der neueren analytischen
Philosophie und auch Harry Frank wird
den schon mal präsentiert hatte auch der
ist ein Urgestein der politischen
Philosophie und die sind eben sehr
präzise und sehr klar im Darstellen von
handlungs theoretischen Probleme
deswegen beziehen wir uns auf Sie und
Donald David 1970 Aufsatz geschrieben
also Davidson hat eigentlich nur
Aufsätze geschrieben hat eigentlich gar
kein Buch geschrieben das ist für die
analytische Philosophie nicht so wichtig
Bücher zu schreiben sondern da schreibt
man lieber kurze und kompakt Aufsätze
und veröffentlicht die dann im collected
papers also sind immer so 15 bis 20
bereits erschiene Aufsätze
zusammengefasst das ist dann das Buch in
der analytischen Philosophie aber dort
ist einfach die Kultur so dass man keine
Bücher so gerne schreibt weil man das
was man sagen möchte er konzentrieren
möchte und nicht so ausschweifen möchte
so könnte man jetzt sagen und jetzt habe
ich hier ein Zitate Wille eine Handlung
Person ist schwarze Fernsehen im eigenen
bestmöglichen Urteil zur wieder an und
zwar absichtlich so wieder nicht in
solchen Fällen heißt es mit unter dem
Handeln die Willenskraft um zu tun was
nach seinem Wissen oder zumindest seine
Überzeugung und bei Berücksichtigung
aller Umstände werden
das zweite Zitat ist ziemlich ähnlich
wie das der deswegen überspringe ich und
jetzt haben wir hier noch mal diese
Kurzformel wo sie wieder die analytische
Philosophie dran erkennen die führt
gerne X und Y ein das sind Variablen
eins schön Format und die Sache
irgendwie doch auf den Punkt also dem
der Handelnde oder die x tut handelt sie
dann und nur dann unbeherrscht wenn A
die handelte x-absichtlich tot sie
glaubt eine Alternative Handlung y sein
möglich weil wenn sie unmöglich ist dann
obwohl sie besser sein könnte dann tue
ich halt x weil y ist ja unmöglich aber
y Alternative zu a ist die auch möglich
und die urteilt die Person das unter
Berücksichtigung alle Umstände nicht nur
weil sie sich mal zu wenig Gedanken
gemacht wird und hinterher dann doch
denken würde ach ist doch die Besserung
nein Angesicht aller Möglichkeit Gründe
kommt sie zum Schluss zum urteilen ist
auch ein wichtiges Phänomen der Hand
Philosophie das Y besser wäre als x und
trotzdem tut sie x
und jetzt bringe ich noch eine neue
Folie und das ist jetzt Übersetzung von
mir auch aus diesem Text wie ist
Willensschwäche möglich ist ein
englischer Text da bringt er jetzt hier
so drei Prämissen oder drei ja evidente
Sätze wenn er natürlich ihr tun möchte
als y glaubt frei zu sein entweder X
oder Y zu tun dann wird der intentional
x tun wenn er entweder X oder Y
international tot das ist jetzt alles
ein bisschen verklausuliert wie geht's
einfach nur um das ein Akteur eine
Akteurin am frei sein muss vermeidendes
oder Y das sind wieder die
Handlungsalternativen wenn eine Akteurin
Urteil ist jetzt die zweite evidente
evidente Satz wenn eine Akteurin urteilt
dass es besser wäre nichts zu tun statt
y dann möchte sie nichts mehr tun als y
ja das ist doch eigentlich auch ziemlich
plausibel der zweite Satz leuchtet
unmittelbar ein
und jetzt kommt gibt es noch ein Drittel
Prämisse eine drittes evidentes Phänomen
es gibt unbeherrschte Handlung
ja und aus diesen drei Prämissen die für
Donald Davidson irgendwie
selbst evident sind man kann jetzt immer
bestreiten dass es irgendwie dass das
das ist z.B unbehälter gibt man kann
aber auch einzelne P2 bestreiten so
sieht es aus aber wenn man jetzt sagt
alle drei sind irgendwie evident alle
zwei Prämissen dann so sagt der Witz und
dann handelt es sich hier eigentlich bei
willensschwächung ein Paradox dann
können wir das nicht mehr rational
erklären wir müssen jetzt nicht genau
darauf eingehen das haben wir in dem
letzten Zitat schon gesehen wie kommen
wir dazu wenn wir eine Option B für die
beste halten dann trotzdem obwohl es uns
möglich wäre sie zu tun die andere
Option vorzuziehen wie kommt es dazu
wenn du alle Gründe für die Option
sprechen die ich am Ende nicht wählen
das ist wirklich das Problem und jetzt
sagt er noch folgendes der
akademischhandel der hat weder logisch
Widersprüche die Überzeugung doch ist
einfach sagen notwendigerweise ein
moralisches Versagen was falsch ist dass
der unbeherrschte Mensch irrational
handelt und urteilt denn das muss man
wohl von einem Menschen sagen der gegen
sein eigenes Urteil von handeln wie
können wir gegen unsere Urteilsvermögen
handeln
ja das ist also die Frage und deswegen
sagt auch der Witzen das Besondere an
der Unbeherrschtheit ist dass das
Verhalten im Grunde irration jetzt
müssen wir uns natürlich überlegen gibt
es mögliche Beispiele für binnenschwäche
das ist jetzt ja alles noch sehr
abstrakt aber was spricht denn dafür ich
habe jetzt mal so ein Beispiel gebracht
wir können darüber jetzt auch gleich
noch ein bisschen diskutieren ich habe
gehört dem tutorialen gab es auch schon
ein bisschen Diskussion ich habe in
meiner Zusammenfassung die Intuition
gehabt aber da kann man sich auch wie
immer drüber streiten das ist vielleicht
nicht sowas wie persönliche Aversionen
sind ja das Beispiel eines Gerichtes
gebracht was sehr gesund ist und auch
günstiger ist als ein ungesundes Gericht
das ungesunde Gericht ist auch teurer
und alle Gründe sprechen wirklich
eigentlich dafür und sie essen trotzdem
dann das ungesunde teurer in die
Richtung obwohl eigentlich alles in
ihnen sagt alles vernünftige in ihnen
sagt ist das gesündere es ist besser für
dich es ist günstiger warum bist du
jetzt das ungesunde Gericht und jetzt
könnte man zum Beispiel diskutieren dass
ich dabei um persönlich Aversionen Geld
handelt weil man könnte davon ausgehen
dass Aversion eigentlich keine Gründe
sind also die handelnde Person würde
dann abversion nicht als im eigenen
Grund ansehen aber darüber kann man
jetzt gleich diskutieren weiter Kandidat
ist häufig Emotionen aber Version geht
häufig auch so ein bisschen Emotionen
sind wir da spielt bei unserer Emotionen
Ungeheuerlichkeit wie häufig eben auch
will Schwäche verstanden wird hat ein
bisschen was von
emotionaler Unordnung sage ich mal das
sind einfach durcheinander geraten
aber um jetzt dann noch absichtlich wenn
die Emotionen uns treiben das ist ja die
Bedingung von aggressiv dass wir sie
Absichten tun die eigentlich nicht
nahegelegt die Option zu wählen bei
Emotionen könnte man sagen wir sind da
einfach nur Spielball unsere Emotionen
unsere gef wir sind überwältigt wir sind
gar nicht wir entscheiden uns gar nicht
absichtlich sondern irgendwas in uns
also das ist darüber kann man wirklich
diskutieren man kann auch wirklich in
Frage stellen das würde auch in der
Philosophie getan wird immer noch getan
kann es überhaupt Willensschwäche geben
in dieser Form wie Donald Davidson sie
hier uns dargestellt hat ja und darüber
kann man jetzt noch ein bisschen
diskutieren bevor man dann zum Thema
Handlungsfreiheit dem eigentlichen Thema
der heutigen Sitzung übergehen
ja also wir haben darüber diskutiert ob
vielleicht Müdigkeit also diese
ordentliche Wecker Situation
ein Fall von willenschwäche ist das
einfach noch den Wecker ein bisschen
länger stellen und noch mal ein bisschen
länger schlafen alles dafür spricht
jetzt aufzustehen und wir haben auch
diskutiert die Frage ob vielleicht auch
das Unterbewusstsein so ein Grund sein
kann dass wir das billige tun was uns
unser Urteil prima Fazit eigentlich
nicht empfiehlt dass wir das trotzdem
tun weil vielleicht unterbewusst gar
nicht sichtbar gewisse Faktoren uns
bewegen das könnte man durchaus
diskutieren im Kontext von Willen
Schwächen ja jetzt gehen wir endlich
sage ich mal auf das Thema
Handlungsfreiheit über das dieser
Begriff der Freiheit der war immer
wieder verbunden mit allen Begriffen
ganz wichtiger Begriff ich sag mal
allgemein was zum Thema Freiheit also
Freiheit kann man in ganz verschiedenen
hin verstehen man kann Freiheit
verstehen das werde ich jetzt auch noch
auf den begriffsschema ergänzen das kam
mir jetzt gerade weil man kann
entsprechend von einer positiven
Freiheit und einer negativen Freiheit
also positiv ist die positive freiheit
ist die Freiheit so etwas und negativ
ist die negative freiheit ist die
Freiheit von etwas ja sie sind frei von
zwang sie sind frei von Einschränkung
das ist jetzt aber noch nicht die volle
Freiheit sie müssen immer auch frei zu
etwas sein aber man kann natürlich sagen
wir sind immer erst frei zu etwas wenn
wir frei von etwas sind haben iPhone
Hindernisse die uns in den Weg gestellt
werden das ist eine wichtige
Unterscheidung bei einer positiven so
und negative freiheit ist die Freiheit
von dann kann man natürlich auch noch
wenn man ganz allgemein von Freiheit
spricht sprechen von politischer
Freiheit da sehen sie schon wieder es
geht Richtung kollektive Personen
kollektive phänom
Phänomene wir sprechen jetzt aber hier
jetzt vor allem von der Freiheit die das
Individuum trifft können aber immer
wieder dann auch den Blick auf
kollektive Phänomene werfen und so der
Freiheitsbegriff der uns als erster
einfällt ist der wenn sie mal Umfrage
machen
wann sind sie frei
95% aller Menschen sagen behaupte ich
mal wenn es nicht gerade eine
Philosophen oder philosophisch ist
würden Sie sagen wenn ich tun kann was
ich will dann bin ich frei
und es würden auch 95% aller Menschen
als völlig ausreichend der achten
und da können wir eigentlich auch mal
eine Frage kurz machen aber jetzt keine
online ist und einfach mal hier einfach
mal so
wer von ihnen würde sagen dass
tun zu können was man will die volle
Freiheit ist
jedenfalls die These dass man frei ist
wenn man tun kann was man will das ist
vielleicht die prominenteste Definition
von Freiheit und das ist die
handlungsfall tun können was man will
jetzt gibt es aber noch eine andere
Freiheit das ist die Willensfreiheit wie
geht's der nächsten Sitzung das ist die
Willen frei und die heißt ganz analog
wollen können was man will das ist jetzt
aber natürlich total paradox ne warum
soll ich denn noch mal Rollen was ich
will
wollen können was man will oder mein
wollen selbst noch mal wollen können ja
warum soll ich denn mich noch mal will
endlich zu meinem Willen verhalten
können
Sie ahnen wahrscheinlich schon worauf
das hinausläuft wir haben diesen
philosophischen besprochen da ist auch
Harry Frank wird wieder so ein
Bezugspunkt auf den kommenden nächsten
Sitzung der hat ja gesagt
volition zweiter Stufe wir wollen das
ein Wunsch handlungswirksam wird da
beziehen wir uns auf unseren Willen im
weitesten Sinne all unsere Wünsche aber
unsere Wille wird uns zum Problem und
das ist gerade so ein Fall wo wir
unseren Willen willentlich bestimmen
können ja wir wollen wir wollen das ein
bestimmter Wunsch unser Wille sein das
kann man jetzt im weiteren Sinne so
fassen wir können wollen was man was wir
wollen
und darauf kommen aber in den nächsten
sitzen zu sprechen jetzt geht's heute
erstmal nur um die Frage wenn wir einen
Willen haben
der die Herkunft des Willens ist jetzt
gar nicht thematisch und wir haben ein
Bild das wird jetzt einfach
vorausgesetzt und de facto haben wir ja
auch immer irgendwie ein und dann stellt
sich die Frage können wir das tun was
wir wollen dann sind wir handlungsfrei
Willensfreiheit betrifft die Frage sind
wir auch selbst die
früheren Akteure die Urheberinnen und
Urheber unseres Willens selbst als ist
es wirklich unserer Wille oder ist der
vielleicht manipuliert worden und
einfach eingespeist worden und wir
denken es sei unsere Wille weil wir uns
wo finden ja das heißt Willensfreiheit
wie sie ahnen können ist normal viel
voraussetzungsreiche und viel
anspruchsvoller als Handlungsfreiheit
natürlich genügt es nicht nur unseren
Willen bestimmen zu können wir müssen
den Willen am Ende immer in der Handlung
umsetzen das ist klar
aber die Willensfreiheit die setzt noch
mal eine Ebene tiefer oder höher wie man
sieht wie man sehen möchte die setzt
hier am Willen selbst noch mal die nimmt
den Willen nicht für selbstverständlich
dann sagt da müssen wir gerade weiter
nachforschen wir müssen selbst die
Urheberinnen und Urheber unseres Willens
selbst sein da kommt dann auch der
Begriff der Autonomie der
Selbstgesetzgebung noch ein Spiel aber
das machen wir jetzt den nächsten
Sitzung und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen mal
ein paar Philosophen vorstellen die was
zum Thema Handlungsfreiheit gesagt haben
und auch so ein bisschen gegen
Willensfreiheit also es gibt in der
Philosophie Geschichte eine starke
Tendenz zu argumentieren dass es
willenfreiheit gar nicht geben kann also
nur handlungsfeier wie immer ist alles
Schritte aber es gibt gute Argumente
dafür dagegen und diesen netten Herrn
kennen sie ich habe ihn schon einmal auf
einem T-Shirt hier in der Vorlesung
entdeckt
heute ist er glaube ich nicht auf dem
T-Shirt drauf also das war artisch
schuppenhauer und sie sehen das ist noch
eine
Fotografie
eineotypie vermutlich manchmal also
Mitte des 19 Jahrhunderts gab es schon
die ersten Vorläufer der heutigen
Fotografie also das ist jetzt kein
Gemälde sondern der er wirklich aus und
der hat jetzt ein Zitat ich möchte jetzt
einfach mal nur so kurz anreisen er sagt
das Selbstbewusstsein eine sie jeden Tag
sehr deutlich aus dass er tun kann was
er will Handlungsfreiheit sondern auch
ganz entgegengesetzte Handlung als von
ihm gewollt gedacht werden können so
folgt allerdings dass er auch
entgegengesetztes tun kann wenn er will
dies verwechselt nun der ruheverstand
damit dass er in einem gegebenenfall wo
etwas will auch entgegengesetztes wollen
können und nennt dies die Freiheit des
Films
allein dass sie in einem gegebenenfall
entgegengesetztes wollen können ist
schlechterdings nicht in obiger Aussage
enthalten sondern bloß dies das von zwei
entgegengesetzten Handlung er wenn er
diese will sie tun kann und wenn er jene
will sie ebenfalls tun kann ob er aber
die eine sowohl als die andere ihm
gegebenenfall wollen können bleibt
dadurch unaus gemacht und ist Gegenstand
einer tiefen Untersuchung
also hier wird jetzt problematisiert
dass wir Willensfreiheit haben dass wir
als ein Willen haben können der immer
letztendlich zu beiden Alternativen
gleichzeitig abziehen wir können
verschiedene Handlungen Optionen wollen
aber in einer Situation wo wir etwas
wollen können wir eigentlich nicht
zugleich verschiedenes wollen der Wille
will ja immer nur eine Sache haben der
Wille müsste sich irgendwie aufspalten
und dieses Phänomen bestreitet
artischockenbauer und wir werden das
habe jetzt noch mal so ganz kurz gegeben
als eine Kritik der willenfreiheit und
sie müssen nicht das so vorstellen wir
haben ein Wille Handlung a und ein Wille
Handlung B und häufig wird
mindestfreiheit so vorgestellt als ob
der Wille beides zugleich wolle
aber stellen sich mal ein Wille vor der
zugleich Handlung a und Handlung B will
ich spreche jetzt hier ganz so als ob
der Wille eine Person wäre und das
werden wir jetzt auf den Folien im
folgenden auch noch problematisieren der
Wille will natürlich nichts ja sondern
die Person will etwas ja auch diese Rede
von Wille als Subjekt oder als Substanz
als eines Dinges das etwas tut ist
eigentlich völlig unpräzis haben da
werden wir gleich noch
das ist das Problem kann der Wille sich
wirklich so aufteilen also er muss doch
bestimmt sein der Wille
kann er denn zu beiden bestimmt sein ja
wir sind frei beides zu tun aber wenn
wir etwas wollen dann wollen wir etwas
Bestimmtes wir wollen ihm wollen nicht
eine Dualität das würde der glitzeristen
und das kritisiert dass man so tut als
ob der Wille hier in sich gespalten wird
wenn wir etwas wollen wollen wir was ja
und nicht noch die Alternative davon ne
sonst wäre der Wille nämlich ein
unbestimmtes Vermögen das ist eine
riesen Debatte gewesen können wir uns
den Willen als ein völlig indifferentes
Vermögen vorstellen aber selbst wenn
alle Gründe für etwas sprechen immer
noch auch gleich das andere irgendwie
wollen gut oder so das ist ziemlich
problematisch ja deswegen sehen sich so
etwas
gespalten ist vorzustellen und da können
wir gerne auch gleich noch ein bisschen
drüber diskutieren haben sie dazu noch
bemerkt
ich möchte jetzt
Philosophen bringen weiterhin
Philosophen der noch ein bisschen älter
ist als autoschubmauer der noch ein paar
bessere Argumente bringt warum wir die
These vertreten könnten es gibt nur
Handlungsfreiheit und keine
Willensfreiheit und das ist niemand
geringeres als der englische Philosoph
John Lock der hat im 17 Jahrhundert
überwiegen gelebt und er hat eine
Schrift verfasst das Englisch original
Essay concerning human and standing
ursprünglich erschien 1690
und die deutsche Übersetzung lautet
versucht über den menschlichen Verstand
das ist ein sogenannter empiristischer
Philosoph im piristisch heißt für ihn
zählt für die Frage was wir wissen
können immer die Erfahrung zunächst also
unsere Sinnesdaten unsere Eindrücke
unsere Ideen er fragt woher kommen wir
zu den Ideen von bestimmten Dingen
unsere Ideen wie entstehen die Begriffe
könnte man auch sagen aber er spricht
von ideas woher haben wir uns die Ideen
z.B die Idee der Freiheit die dreht sich
jetzt woher kommt die Idee der Freiheit
und dann muss er zeigen dass das
irgendwie aus unserer Erfahrung kommt
also wie können wir die Idee durch die
Erfahrung begründet und das ist
entgegengesetzt die Rationalismus als
Empirismus schon Lock gibt's auch noch
die andere Seite die Rationalisten die
sagen dann diese Ideen die stammen aus
der Vernunft
und nicht aus der Erfahrung an manche
sagen wir sind uns Eingeborene Ideen
manche sagen die sind einfach
Grundbestandteil unserer Rationalität
und Rationalität ist immer schon auf die
Welt bezogen und deswegen können wir
durch unsere Vernunft Ideen auch die
Wirklichkeit erkennen jede Theorie
werden sie noch genau später dann
feststellen hat ihre Vor- und Nachteile
das hier ist jetzt eine empiristische
Theorie und die besagte müssen die Idee
der Freiheit jetzt erstmal weiter
analysieren durch Erfahrung und er
bestimmt jetzt die Idee der Freiheit als
eine Kraft er sagt
Freiheit ist eigentlich so was wie Kraft
oder Power denken Sie an die positive
Freiheit Freiheit so etwas da haben Sie
immer einen kraftaspekt im Hintergrund
ich bringe jetzt ein paar Zitate aus
diesem Berg er sagt so betrachtet ist
die Kraft eine zweifache nämlich das
Vermögen eine Veränderung herbeizufügen
oder eine solche zu erleiden das eine
können wir die Aktiven das andere die
passive Kraft nennen ihm geht's
natürlich darum um eine Änderung
herbeizuführen und das nennt die aktive
Kraft wir können das auch die positive
Freiheiten nach unseren Begriffen wohl
jeder findet sagte weiter in sich selbst
eine Kraft bestimmte Handlung in sich
anzufangen oder zu unterlassen
vorzusetzen oder abzuschließen
aus der Betrachtung des Umfangs dieser
Macht des Geistes über die Handlung des
Menschen die jeder in sich selbst findet
entstehen die Ideen von Freiheit er sagt
nicht freedom er sagt Liberty und
Notwendigkeiten acacity
also Freiheit die Idee der Freiheit ich
möchte jetzt erklären wie kommen wir
überhaupt sind die kommt hier von einer
macht oder Kraft ist Geistes über die
Handlungen also können wir das tun was
wir wollen dann sind wir frei haben wir
die Macht können wir es nicht sind wir
nicht frei sind wir beschränkt und jetzt
wieder noch ein bisschen genauer die
Ideen
von der Notwendigkeit erklären er sagt
so ist die Idee der Freiheit die Idee
einer macht die einhandelndes Wesen hat
irgendeine Handlung zu vollziehen oder
zu unterlassen gemäß der Entscheidung
oder dem Gedanken des Geistes und bei
eines zum anderen vorgezogen wird oder
das handelnde Wesen nicht die Macht hat
das eine von beiden seiner Willen
Äußerung gemäß zu bewirken da fehlt ihm
die Freiheit ein solches Wesen der
Notwendigkeit und wennigkeiten also
so Handlungsfreiheit
Freiheit kann also dort nicht sein sagt
er weiter wo es kein Denken keine
Willensäußerung keinen Willen gibt wohl
aber können denken Wille Willens äußern
darf vorhanden sein wo es keine Freiheit
gibt das ist jetzt ein interessante
Passage also am Denken und
Willensäußerung sind die Basis für
Freiheit Freiheit entsteht ihr es da wo
denken und willens Äußerung sind aber
denken Wille will es Äußerung sind nicht
hinreichend
für
die Freiheit also es kann praktisch die
vorliegen geben diese Phänomene diese
kognitiven phänomente und trotzdem gibt
es keine Freiheit sie nennen sich an
Harry Frank wird hatte gesagt die von
Null selbst die brauchen wir um frei zu
sein um einen freien Willen zu haben
aber sie ist noch nicht hinreichend
dafür wir brauchen die Vernunft und es
dann haben wir diesen
selbstreflexiven Willen wenn wir die von
uns schon voraussetzen das heißt also
mit der rein Rationalität haben wir noch
nicht Freiheit gewonnen da muss noch
mehr passieren Freiheit ist also nicht
eine Idee die die Willensäußerung oder
das Vorziehen betrifft sie betrifft viel
mehr die Person deren macht es steht
gemäß der Wahl oder Verfügung des
Geistes etwas zu tun oder zu unterlassen
also jetzt ganz wichtig dass die
Freiheit immer auf die Person gezogen
wird und jetzt gibt es noch ein bisschen
die Wiederholung er sagt unsere Idee der
Freiheit reicht so weit wie diese macht
aber nicht weiter wenn du irgendein
Hindernis dieser Macht Schranken sitzt
oder Zwang die Möglichkeit des Handelns
oder nicht Handelns aufheben da hört
sofort die Freiheit und der Begriff von
mir auf also die Freiheit wird begrenzt
durch unsere Kraft
und ersetzt eben dieser dieser Freiheit
die Notwendigkeit oder den Zwang
Entgegenkommen all das ist praktisch
gerade am das was Freiheit nicht erlaubt
wenn sie gezwungen sind wenn sie auch
gehemmt sind dann kann letztendlich die
Macht die Kraft die sie in sich haben
ausbilden das können Sie ganz einfach so
vorstellen wenn Sie etwas tun wollen und
man schränkt sie ein Mann umfasst sie
man hinterziehman liegt in Fesseln an so
können sich das vorstellen da hat dann
einfach Ihre Handlungsfreiheit ihre
Grenzen und jetzt kommt eigentlich weil
jetzt sagt er der Wille ist nicht frei
oder unfrei also wir können gar nicht
davon sprechen dass er frei sei das ist
ein Kategorienfehler die Frage ob der
Wille des Menschen frei ist sagt er ist
ebenso sinnlos wie die ob sein Schlaf
geschwind oder seine Tugend viereckig
denn die Freiheit lässt sich ebenso
wenig auf den Willen anwenden wie die
Geschwindigkeit einer Bewegung auf den
Schlaf oder die Figur eines Vierecks auf
die Tugend ja das ist jetzt noch ein
bisschen seltsam ja also er sagt
den Willen frei zu nennen also das
Prädikat frei auf dem Willen zu beziehen
ist genauso unsinnig wie dann das
Prädikat viereckig auf die Tugend zu
beziehen das sind ganz andere man
spricht davon auch von Kategorien
Fehlern wenn ich zum Beispiel sage heute
Abend ist der Mond aber böse laut
würden Sie sagen ja das ist
vielleicht eine metaphorische Rede aber
das ist kann er nicht ernst meine wenn
ich sage die Heizung ist aber geizig
wenn sie denken vielleicht weil sie
jetzt so ausgeschaltet ist weil sie kalt
ist will ich damit irgendwie poetisch
was ausdrücken so ja aber es gibt keinen
Sinn einfach das gehört nicht zu sagen
ja ich kann auch nicht sagen dass die
dass die fünfte Zahl fünf dass die
nachher riecht dass die nachher
Geschmack geschmeckt oder so ja dass die
gut schmeckt die Zahl fünf ja
fünf kannst du nicht essen ja so und
genauso absurd sagt er wäre es den
Willen Freizeit da haben wir natürlich
verschiedene Intuition dagegen da würden
wir sagen also ich spreche immer davon
dass meine
meine völlige Grundüberzeugung dass man
wieder frei ist er sagt nein das ist ein
völliger Kategorien fehlen es ist das
Prädikat frei die Eigenschaft frei die
kann sich gar nicht auf den Willen
beziehen weil der Wille nehme ich bitte
gleich sehen der gar nichts ist was ein
Prädikat haben kann es ist somit klar
dass mir nichts ist als eine Kraft oder
Fähigkeit fragen ob dem Willensfreiheit
zukommen heißt also wissen wollen ob
eine Kraft eine andere Kraft eine
Fähigkeit eine andere Fähigkeit besitze
was schon auf den ersten Blick zu absurd
ist als dass man darüber streiten können
oder eine Antwort darauf zu geben
brauchte denn wir sehen nicht dass
Kräfte nur handelnden Wesen zu kommen
und ausschließlich Attribute als
Eigenschaften von Substanz von Dingen
aber nicht von anderen Kräften sind wer
die Frage so stellt nämlich auf den
Freizeit fragt mit ihnen Wirklichkeit ob
der Wille eine Substanz anhand des Wesen
sein oder ersetzt dies zumindest voraus
da die Freiheit genau genommen nichts
anderes zugeschrieben werden kann er
bringt ja also das Argument der Wille
kann deswegen nicht frei genannt werden
weil der Wille gar nichts ist was frei
sein kann von seiner Art hätte Wille ist
nämlich nicht eine Substanz ein Ding was
verschiedene Eigenschaften haben kann
das Pulli ist gelb und so dürfen wir
nicht den Willen verstehen dass sie
sagen der Wille ist frei sind der Wille
ist selbst eine Eigenschaft oder er sagt
auch später noch eine Fähigkeit oder
Relation also den Willen selbst wenn man
gar keine Eigenschaften zu sprechen das
kann man natürlich weiter kritisch
hinterfragen
wenn man die Freiheit in korrekter
Redeweise überhaupt auf eine Kraft
anwenden kann so lässt sie sich
derjenigen Kraft zu schreiben die ein
Mensch in sich hat um Durchwahl oder
bevorzugten eine Bewegung in einzelnen
Teilen seines Körpers zu erzeugen oder
die Erzeugung zu unterlassen hier sehen
wir also Freiheit hat auch was mit
Unterlassung zu tun da lassen ist auch
nachts eine Handlung das aber ist ist ja
ist gerade weshalb man den Menschen
einen es ist die Freiheit selbst sollte
aber jemand fragen ob die Freiheit frei
sei so würde man nehmen das in seine
eigenen Worte nicht verstehen
also die Kraft ist ja schon die Freiheit
der Wille ist eine Kraft die Freiheit
ausdrückt dass wir eigentlich von ihm
gar nicht fragen können ob er frei sei
so jedenfalls schon
wenn es sinnvoll wäre Fähigkeiten als
besondere also Fähigkeiten wie den
Willen Fähigkeiten als besondere Wesen
anzunehmen die handeln können und in
diesem Sinne von ihm zu sprechen was zum
Beispiel geschieht wenn wir sagen der
Wille befiehlt und frei dann müssten wir
auch besondere Fähigkeiten zum Reden zu
gehen und zum Tanzen annehmen durch die
die betreffenden Tätigkeiten erzeugt
würden dabei sind diese doch nur
verschiedene Mode der Bewegung ebenso
betrachten als Fähigkeiten die
Tätigkeiten des Willens und Wahrnehmens
erzeugen während
des Denkens sind also der Wille gar
nichts und der Mensch die Person
befiehlt durch den Willen
und jetzt kommen noch ein Argument
Kräfte wie der Wille ein Kraft ist oder
auch die Freiheit sind Relationen nicht
handelnde Wesen nur das was die Kraft zu
wirken besitzt oder nicht besitzt ist
frei oder nicht frei die Kraft selbst
ist es nicht den Freiheit oder
Unfreiheit kann nur dem zukommen was die
Kraft zu handeln besitzt oder nicht
besitzen jetzt kommen zum Fazit Freiheit
besteht also in der Kraft zu handeln
oder das Handel zu unterlassen und zwar
nur darin jetzt wollen wir hier so ein
bisschen Inhalten und mal darüber
diskutieren was sind dafür spricht oder
nicht wird schon locks Zürich ich bin
aber noch ein Zitat davor um jedoch zu
uns zu untersuchen der Freiheit
zurückzukehren zu heißen meines
Erachtens die richtige Fragestellung
nicht ist der will frei sondern ist der
Menschheit
und
das ist dann praktisch die Definition so
weit nun diese Kraft reicht zu Handel
oder nicht zu handeln je nachdem ob die
Entscheidung seines Denkens die eine
oder andere Möglichkeit bevorzugt so
weit ist der Mensch frei
ja darüber würde ich jetzt gerne mit ihm
diskutieren kann der Wille freign
genannt werden oder eigentlich gar nicht
und was sind die Argumente wird schon
Lock dafür zu argumentieren zu plädieren
dass der Wille nicht frei ist
also wir haben gesehen John Lock ist
sehr sehr skeptisch was überhaupt auf
begriffliche Ebene die Willensfreiheit
anbelangt er sagt phänomenologisch
intuitiv sehen wir täglich uns wir
kennen das dass wir einen Willen haben
und dass wir ihn umsetzen können eine
Handlung es passiert aber auch manchmal
dass wir ein willenlos haben und wir
werden gehindert vielleicht aus welchen
Gründen auch immer aus machtgründen das
dicke fesselt sind und so weiter und so
fort da sind wir einfach nicht
handlungsfrei da ist unsere macht
einfach begrenzt erreicht uns zu machen
das sagte auch nur der Mensch ist frei
zu nennen und jetzt bringt er aber doch
eine Definition für die Freiheit
vielleicht sogar die Freiheit des
Willens und die möchte ich auch noch
hier eine da der Geist sagt er wie die
Erfahrung zeigt in den meisten Fällen
die Kraft besitzt bei der Verwirklichung
und Befriedigung irgendeines Wunsches
inne zu halten und mit allen anderen
Wünschen der reine ebenso zu verfahren
so hatte auch die Freiheit ihre Objekte
zu betrachten die von allen Seiten zu
prüfen und gegen andere abzulegen ihren
besteht die Freiheit die der Mensch
besitzt aus deren falschen gebraucht die
ganze Fülle von missgriffen Irrtümern
und Fehlern stammen in die wir in unsere
Lebensführung unter unserem Leben nach
Glück hinein geraten wenn wir unsere
Entscheidung stürzen und vor schnell
ohne rechte Prüfung zu handeln beginnen
um dem vorzubeugen haben wir die Kraft
die Verfolgung dieses oder jenes
Wunsches zu unterbrechen
die jeder täglich bei sich selbst
erproben kann also er geht hier von der
Alltagserfahrung
hier in dieser Fähigkeit
unsere Wünsche zu unterbrechen also zu
hemmen wir scheinbar die Quelle aller
Freiheit zu liegen ihren scheint das zu
bestehen was man meines Erachtens
unzutreffend den freien Willen nennt ja
also das ist so zu verstehen wir haben
verschiedene Wünsche in uns vielleicht
sogar auch willenstendenzen und jetzt
sagt er wenn überhaupt das
Willensfreiheit gibt die Freiheit des
Willen dann darin dass wir zurücktreten
können das nennt man psychologisch ich
habe schon erwähnt inhibition also
Hemmung wir verspüren uns verschiedene
Tendenzen und wir sind dann besonders
frei wenn wir Herrscherinnen und
Herrscher über unsere Tendenzen sind das
heißt wir können will endlich das ist
die Frage willentlich von unseren
Wünschen zurücktreten
hier bezieht sich also der Wille
irgendwie auf dem Bild ja ich will
nämlich dass ich nicht diesen Willen
jetzt gleich habe und dann zur Handlung
kommt sondern ich will mich in eine
Distanz zu mir setzen eine willentliche
und da wird der Wille irgendwie reflexiv
und hier hält also schon locks eine
kleine Option offen dafür dass wir
vielleicht doch
Willensfreiheit haben können in dem
Sinne dass wir willentlich auf den
Willen reflektieren und nicht nur tun
was wir wollen also der Wille wird hier
diesen Zitaten hat schon selbst reflexiv
und das führt dann auch wieder zu Harry
Frank wird wie wir gesehen haben dass
sie sind Willen will den wir eben
entscheiden welcher Wunsch unser Wille
sein soll und handlungswirksam sein soll
also hier sieht man schon seine
reflexiven Dimension jetzt gibt's
verschiedene Argumente für die
Handlungsfreiheit die nochmal zusammen
die haben halt kennengelernt nicht der
Wille ist frei ist ein Argument sondern
der andere Mensch es keine
Willensfreiheit also von Willensfreiheit
zu sprechen ist ist einfach ein
Kategorienfehler das war das Argument
von John Lock der Grund warum wir
geneigt sind zu sagen der will es sei
frei besteht darin dass wir diesen
Willen als ein handelndes Wesen
betrachten also nun zu
ungerechtfertigter Weise personifizieren
dies führt nach John Locken zu einer
Gedanken Verwirrung der Wille ist eine
Kraft oder Fähigkeit
als ist als Kraftfähigkeit nur eine
Eigenschaft von Menschen der Wille
selbst ist nichts was unabhängig von
Menschen wie ein quasi Akteur existiert
Eigenschaften wie der Wille sie ist
können nicht für sich selbst existieren
sondern brauchen etwas dem sie anhaften
ja man kann zum Beispiel sagt jetzt
schlecht fragen welche Eigenschaften
eine Eigenschaft hat
ja also
wir müssen immer von dem Ding fragen
ob es die Eigenschaft hat nicht von der
Eigenschaft ob sie ein Eigenschaft hat
ja also ist der Wille frei wäre zu
fragen ist die Eigenschaft kräftig zu
sein
kräftig der freien das ist für ihn
jedenfalls plausibel
der Wille und die Freiheit haften als
Eigenschaften den Menschen an und die
Quelle unserer Freiheit liegt in unserer
Fähigkeit unsere Wünsche und Begehung zu
hemmen sagt schon lockt und aus einer
kritischen Distanz zu reflektieren
und für unsere Freiheit genügt es das
tun zu können was wir tun wollen und wir
brauchen nicht weiter zu fragen ob wir
wollen können was man will obwohl es
diese eine Passage gibt die ich Ihnen
gezeigt habe wo er sagt die Quelle ist
die Reflexion die Hemmung unserer
Willens Tendenz ja das ist jetzt mal so
ein paar sind jetzt ein paar
philosophische Argumente gewesen die die
Richtung gehen dass sie sagen es gibt
nur Handlungsfreiheit und nicht
Willensfreiheit also ist genügt wenn wir
tun können was wir wollen und wir müssen
selbst nicht noch den Willen groß der
Fragen der nächsten Sitzung ist der
Ausblick in der nächsten Sitzung werden
wir uns jetzt mit der bildungsfrei
befassen Willensfreiheit besteht im
Gegensatz zur Handlungszeit darin
unseren Willen selbst zu bestimmen
also da wird einfach vorausgesetzt es
genügt nicht zu tun was man will sondern
selbst muss kritisch geprüft und
reflektiert werden es könnte sein
dass in unseren wildfaktoren eingehen
die eigentlich nicht aus unserem
Innersten stammen wir könnten zum
Beispiel uns ein Fall vorstellen wo wir
einfach einen Willen eingepflanzt
bekommen wir werden manipuliert südlich
unsere Wünsche und sind eigentlich gar
nicht die Autoren Autoren die
UrheberInnen
das heißt willenskreis noch mal viel
anspruchsvoller als handlungsfrei wir
müssen kurz gesagt selbst die Ursache
unseres wollen sein und nicht nur unsere
Handlung ja Handlungsfreiheit sagt wir
müssen die Ursachen sein müssen wenn wir
ein Bild haben den
willensfreiheitstheoretikerinnen und
Theoretiker gesagt nein wir müssen nicht
nur am Ende tun können was wir wollen
sondern der Anfangspunkt der Wille
selbst muss erstmal geprüft werden ob
wir überhaupt dahinter stehen
jetzt kann man natürlich sagen genügt es
nicht einfach schon etwas zu wollen
wieso sollen wir denn wenn wir etwas
wollen diesen Willen noch mal
hinterfragen wenn ich etwas will will
ich was perfekt und jetzt muss ich nur
noch dafür sorgen dass der Wille in der
Handlung umgeführt umgesetzt wird warum
soll ich denn überhaupt mein wollen noch
mal ja gut weil ich eben nicht sicher
sein kann über meinen wollen viele sagen
wer weiß woher der Wille kommt es könnte
sein der Wille ist man wird und es ist
eigentlich gar nicht unser Wille die
müssen also uns unseren Willen oder das
was wir uns als Triebe Neigungen Wünsche
vorfinden erst noch mal selbst
reflektieren ja und hier kommt noch ein
weiterer Begriff ins Spiel nämlich der
Begriff der Autonomie und der besagt
folgendes wir müssen uns selbst die
Gesetze unseres Handelns und wollen es
geben
handeln und wollen Freiheit mit immer
nur angesichts von Gesetzen statt als
von Regel und diese Regeln dürfen uns
nicht von außen gegeben werden das wäre
die sogenannte heterung das heißt
kritische fremdgesetzgebung sondern sie
müssen autonom sein Autos ist selbst und
nochmals ist das Gesetz also wir selbst
müssen die UrheberInnen derjenigen
Gesetze sein derjenigen nachdem sich
unser Handeln und wollen richtet und
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen
inwiefern sind wir frei uns die Gesetze
des Wollens und Handelns zu geben sind
wir das überhaupt können wir das
überhaupt und jetzt kann man weiter
fragen was sind überhaupt die Gesetze
und Regeln nachdem wir wenn wir frei
sein wollen unser Handeln wollen
ausrichten soll oder müssen und das wird
uns dann auf Immanuel Kant noch mal
bringen die man kann sagt wir sind nur
dann autonomen wenn wir nach spanischen
Gesetzen
wenn also die Gesetze die unser Wollen
und Handeln regeln wenn das ja das
moralisch gute ist der kategorisch
Imperativ den haben wir ja schon mal
kennt wenn das unser Handel bestimmt
dieses Sittengesetz dann sind wir auf
aber wie sieht's dann aus wenn wir
unmoralisch handelt wenn wir das Böse
tun sind wir dann auch noch autonom da
geben wir uns ja selbst ein Gesetz
nämlich das Gesetz nicht dem 7 gesetzt
zu folgen sondern dem Gesetz weiß nicht
unsere Neigung oder so sind dann auch
noch autonom ja und eine weitere Frage
ist wie verhalten sich Freiheit und
Determinismus zueinander würde schon
richtig bewährt
Handlungsfreiheit ist eigentlich völlig
kompatibel da hören sie noch einen neuen
Begriff kompatibilismus also
Vereinbarkeit ist Freiheit vereinbar mit
determination mit vorher Bestimmung oder
mit Bestimmung handlungsfrei ist
kompatibel weil es interessiert in der
Handlungsfreiheit nicht ob der Wille
fremde stimmt wurde sondern der Wille
wird einfach nur vorausgesetzt der Markt
bestimmten Faktoren unterliegen
interessiert mich aus der Perspektive
der Handlungsfreiheit nicht interessiert
mich nur ob ich den Willen den ich nun
mal habe der stimmt sein kann ist ob der
zu einer Handlungsführung bei der
Willensfreiheit wird die Frage nach der
detention noch viel schwieriger weil da
muss ich sicherstellen dass mein Wille
nicht so vorherbestimmt ist dass es
nicht wenn meiner Macht steht ja dass
als die Naturgesetze letztendlich meinen
wollen Stimmen sind da muss ich selbst
die Ursache sein und wie kann ich denn
eine Ursache meines wollen sein wenn ich
doch andererseits ein natürliches Wesen
bin was durch alle Naturgesetz
eigentlich vollständig erklärbar sein
muss als sonst würde in der Natur
Gesetzmäßigkeit eine Lücke herrschen
dann müsste immer dann wenn ich frei
hatte müssten die Naturgesetze ganz kurz
außer Kraft gesetzt werden alle
deterministischen Naturgesetzen
kurzzeitig verschwinden dann habe ich
die Freiheit irgendwas zu tun und sobald
ich gehandelt habe kommen wieder alle
Naturgesetz ins Spiel das heißt setzt
mein Handeln
in der Naturgesetzlichkeit voraus oder
kann ich mein Handeln kompat als
kompatibel also als vereinbar mit der
vollständigen naturgesetzlichen
determination der Welt denken und ist
die Frage nach kompatibilismus also
Vereinbarkeit von determination und zwei
und von inkompatibilismus also das
freies Handeln und determination nicht
vereinbar miteinander sind da werden wir
auch verschiedene Spielarten dieses
Verhältnisses von Freiheit und
determination kennenlernen das ist dann
das Thema der nächsten sieht so wir
haben jetzt noch kurz Zeit für ein oder
zwei Fragen und dann müssen wir Schluss
machen